18 seven six
lift up
parent want to prepare the tower
if you can hear me over the cheering and
the vehicle is now headed down range in
an easterly Direction over the Atlantic
Ocean our next Ascent Milestone is Max Q
around 80 Seconds
Karen what is supersonic
switch over at the ground station
as you can see we were waiting for Nico
and upper stage ignition this means that
we had a main engine cut off for stage
one and directly following that we had
second stage ignition which you can see
I also don't get down this is the LD
there's been a t plus anomaly with stage
two we'll see please begin a non-link
procedure section 25.
although we didn't reach orbit we
significantly exceeded our key
objectives for this first launch and
that objective was to gather data at Max
Q one of the most demanding phases of
flight and Achieve stage separation